you seem happy
i am happy you should both be happy as
well
not so long ago this city was ready to
devour itself
now it's like a man reborn i will be
happy when our queen returns
why don't you drink why don't either of
you ever drink
and sully never drink why not rules who
made these rules
your former masters those miserable old
shits didn't want you to be human
have a drink with me
and you what's your excuse
i have tried wine before it made me feel
funny that's how you know it's working
here's to our queen
anyone not drinking is disrespecting our
to queen stormborn mother of dragons
breaker of chains
long may she reign
do you like it tastes like it has turned
yes yes fermentation
one day after our queen has taken the
seven kingdoms
i'd like to have my own vineyard
make my own wine the imps delight
only my close friends could drink it
tell me a joke miss sandy of nuth
i do not know any jokes grey worm
right
three lords walk into a tavern
a stark a martel and a lannister they
order ale
but when the barkeep brings them over
each of them
finds a fly in his cup the lannister
outrage shoves the cup aside and demands
another
the martel plucks the fly out and
swallows it whole
the stock reaches into his cup
pulls out the fly and shouts
spit it out your wee spit it out
it's funnier in westeros the starks and
the lannisters
i thought these were enemies yes a joke
is like
a story dork not a true story
necessarily a story that's supposed to
make you laugh
not at the moment perhaps sunday do you
like the wine
i do tell a joke
two translators are on a sinking ship
the first says do you know how to swim
the second says no but i can shout for
help in 19 languages
[Laughter]
that is the worst joke i ever heard you
don't even know what a joke is
i am soldier all my life you think i
never hear joke
you lied to us
i make jokes
more jokes
you